Oh
[Applause]
today we're going to make history today
we're gonna save sonic once and for all
I know this whole sonic thing ain't over
done people are talking about it I just
really want to know for my own personal
reason accent hey how can we make sonic
right they decided that they're gonna
fix sonic I'm here to help I'm here to
give my ok I'm here to give my
suggestions on what that should look
like now first of all I need to find a
picture how do I do that I don't want
that one here we go okay this looks good
high-quality picture god I think first
of all I want to do what's obvious and
let's just see what he would look like
as a classic look I know people have
done this I'm just curious what to make
the eyes smaller later probably liquify
isn't the best way to do this that's
right guys I have saved Sonic you're
welcome
so I'm just placing it right okay look
how much better that looks I think when
I'm starting to realize there's as Sonic
is a cyclops
why is sonic a cyclops and why has no
one questioned this earlier do this
[Music]
I'm starting to realize maybe making a
perfect sonic is it so easy oh my god
that is very eerie Jesus Christ I'm
actually terrified
this will be the sonic.exe movie yeah
all right next up is the mouth Shirley
[Music]
what someone ruined the sonic franchise
what so obviously the eyes are little
thinner doesn't look really that good
really ugly them the noses then it was
looks so bad I think it just needs to be
a little more pointing and that's it
that's all they had to do I don't have
to do this bro I'm gonna fix the
nostrils because they pissed me off
they're disgusting don't give sonic
nostrils that's how you know they messed
up another error I just realized that
makes no sense why is the stomach and
the face different color fir look at
Sonic here they have the same all over
like why they never change that is that
legit just a mistake that's so stupid
look at this how hard it is oh how hard
is it they are fixed god damn this is
pissing me off it's not just the teeth
it's like the whole mouth then legs
there's Dee sucking lips dude so
uncomfortable so there you have it small
details very big difference I don't know
how they mess that up and honestly the
stomach thing blows my mind because I
just seems like incompetence more than
anything then design choices
[Music]
let's try out some different things you
know what they really should have done
let's just grab a real freaking Hedgehog
dub it over with some Japanese dub oh
and then just call it a day okay say
this is better
this is infinitely better it's not gonna
dammit so awful
[Music]
Panasonic is it real
hahaha you ever think that you just
wasting your life away doing dumb
pointless it well then try photoshopping
[Music]
still not worse than her it's gonna look
like the past the booth me
damn day scares me every time yes that's
good
[Music]
why did I waste time on this
hey at least better than the original
I had an idea in my head and now I have
to execute it no matter what
[Music]
Shrek Sonic is coming oh god is so scary
Lord forgive me for what I'm about to do
oh my god
it's strange how similar their mouths
are now that I think about it I did a
bad thing
I regret the thing I did you know
exactly what it is I haven't done the
ears yet
and it's really this is one of those
things you just gotta get to okay all
right god dammit god dammit why okay
let's look at before an actor that's
always fun
before after Wow I prefer Shrek Sonic
but that's just my opinion I kind of
want to share see what people think
about this this is the most fun part for
any artist sharing their work and see
how much people enjoy it no no hey hey
spell those beams Sonic surprise Pikachu
face Sonic what in the world Sonic golem
Sonic why hey all right
[Music]
dr. Phil and Sonic dr. Phil I love you
and I just want to say I'm sorry I
didn't want this to happen someone
suggested it and I realized what I had
to do it looks so good running around at
the speed of sound follow my rainbow I'm
so sorry everyone
[Laughter]
[Music]
good god I don't know why it's so funny
it's not Oh God
let's see what people think of dr. Phil
Shani stop
why Nicolas Cage sonic is a classic of
course you gotta go fast to the ranch
get to the ranch even faster all right I
think that's enough I had a lot of fun
let me know what update of sonic you
want to see in the sonic fix and that's
it for me for now smash like subscribe
check out merch check out tuber
simulator and see you guys out a hundred
mil that was we brofist for a hundred
men let's get it what you never played
to purr simulator you know it's fun
right I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but give it a try and then you
can tell me if it's good or not not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]
spongebob sonic isn't real